Voiceover:Tomas's favorite colors,
Tomas's favorite colors
are blue and green.
He has one blue shirt, one green shirt,
one blue hat, one green scarf,
one blue pair of pants,
and one green pair of pants.
Tomas selects one of
these garments at random.
Let A be the event that
he selects a blue garment.
Let B be the event that
he chooses a shirt.
Which of the following
statements are true?
And they all, let's see,
and before I even read them,
they all deal with the
probability of event A
probability of event B,
probability of B given A,
probability of A given B,
probability of A and B.
So actually let's just calculate
these things ahead of time
before we even look at
these right over here.
So let's just think about,
let's just think about
probability of A.
The probability of A.
That's the probability
that he picks a blue,
he selects a blue garment.
So how many equally
likely outcomes are there?
Well, there's one, two,
three, four, five, six
equally likely outcomes.
And how many involve
selecting a blue garment?
Well, there's one, two, three
of the equally likely outcomes
involve selecting a blue garment.
So he has a 3/6 or 1/2 probability
of selecting a blue garment.
So what's the probability of B?
What's the probability of B?
And I'll use neutral colors
since we're just saying he's B
the event that he chooses a shirt.
So once again, there's six possible items
equally likely outcomes here,
and which involve a shirt.
Well, there's one, there's two,
so it looks like two of the six
involve picking a shirt.
Or we could say the probability
of B is equal to 1/3.
Now what's the probability of A given B?
Let's write that down.
What's the probability of
let's use a new color,
What's the probability of A given B?
I'll do those in the colors.
A given that B has happened.
So this is saying
what's the probability of A given B?
The probability of A given B
is the probability that
he picks a blue garment
given that he has picked a shirt.
So, this the given B that
restricts our outcomes
to these two.
So the probability that
he picks a blue item
well, that's one out of the
two equally likely ones.
So that is a 1/2 probability
that he picks a blue garment
given that he's picked a shirt,
and that's because there is one blue shirt
and one green shirt.
Let's look at the
probability of B given A.
Probability of B given A.
B given, probability of B given A.
So assuming we have picked a blue garment.
So assuming we've picked a blue garment.
So it's either that one or that one.
What's the probability that we have also,
What's the probability that
we have also chosen a shirt?
Well, there's one, two,
three possibilities,
equally likely possibilities
that we have a blue garment.
And only one of those involve a shirt.
So the probability of B given A is 1/3.
And then finally we can think about
probability of A and B.
So the probability, probability,
of A and B, A and B.
So this is the probability
of picking a blue shirt.
So only one out of the six
equally likely outcomes
is a blue shirt.
So this one right over here
is going to be one, one over six.
So now that we've figured out all of that
let's see if we can
answer these questions.
The probability of A given B
equals the probability of A.
And that does work out.
Probability of A given B is 1/2.
And that's the same thing
as the probability of A.
The probability that
Tomas likes a blue garment
given that he has chosen a shirt
is equal to the probability
that Tomas likes a blue garment.
Yep, that's exactly.
So I guess the words are just rephrasing
what they wrote here in
a more mathy notation.
So this is absolutely true.
The probability of B given A
is equal to the probability of B.
Yep, the probability of B given A is 1/3.
The probability of B is 1/3.
The probability that Tomas selects a shirt
given that he has chosen a blue garment
is equal to the probability
that Tomas selects a shirt.
Yep, that's right.
Events A and B are independent events.
Independent events.
So two events are independent
if, well let me write it in math notation.
These are independent if the probability
of A given B is equal to
the probability of A.
Then we can say A and B are independent.
Because the probability of A,
then if this is true then this means
the probability of A given B
isn't dependent on
whether B happened or not.
It's the same thing as
the probability of A.
This would lead to these
events being indpendent.
So if you had the probability of B given A
is equal to the probability of B.
Same argument.
That would mean they are independent.
Or, if we said that the
probability of A and B
is equal to the probability of A
times the probability of B
then this also means they are independent.
We know that this one is true.
The probability of A and B is 1/6.
The probability of A
times the probability of B
is 1/2 times 1/3 which is 1/6.
So all of these are clearly true.
So we can say that A
and B are independent.
The probability of A is independent
of whether B has happened or not.
The probability of B happening
is independent of whether
A has happened or not.
The outcome of events A and B
are dependent on each other.
No.
That's the opposite of
saying they are independent.
So we can cross that out.
Probably of A and B is equal to
the probability of A
times the probability of B
We already said that to be true.
1/6 is 1/2 times 1/3.
The probability that Tom selects
a blue garment that is a shirt
is equal to the probability that tom
selects a blue garment
multiplied by the probability
that he selects a shirt.
Yep.
That is absolutely right.
So actually this is, a lot
of these statements are true.
The only one that is not
is that the outcome of events A and B
are dependent on each other.